Go
OFFICIAL TRAILER
What's up guys?
So, to become an Avenger
are there like trials
or an interview?
Do me a favor.
Can't you just be a friendly
neighbourhood spiderman?
Just stay close to the ground
You're the Spiderman, from Youtube
Can you summon a number of spiders?
No, Ned no!
Do you know him too?
I Stole his shield
Can I try the suit on?
On
July 7
The rich and the powerful, like Stark,
they don't care about us
The world's changing boys, time we change too
This weapons are crazy dangerous.
Listen Peter, forget the flying monster guy
There are people who handle this sort of thing
your legal weapon ferry was at 2:30
You've missed it
No, no, no
What if somebody have died?
I was just trying to be like you
I want you to be better.
I am gonna need your suit back
but I am nothing without this suit
If you are nothing without this suit,
then you shouldn't have it.
I screwed up.
You need to stop carrying weight of the world on your shoulders.
I want you to understand,
I'll do anything to protect my family.
I know you know what I am talking about,
So don't mess with me.
Because I am gonna kill you
and everybody you got
Oh my god!
My friend are there!
GO!
This guy is still out there.
I just got to do this on my own.
Just, don't do anything stupid.
I've got this
All right?
Yeah.